all right comp beast i mean
i kind of screwed you i mean you've had
a chance to sit for a bit now that
you've been evicted are you in any way
shocked it happened
no i i knew the i knew the wins would
add up and they did just a lot sooner
than i thought i didn't think i'd have
five wins by week five which
is i'm extremely happy about but it did
end up biting me in the butt it's just
the defending point is i had to win week
one otherwise i would have been the
first person home
and then at the end that big kiss that's
what everyone's talking about
that was a loaded kiss it was
it was a goodbye it was i'm gonna miss
you it's gonna see you and gonna be a
see you in good or
see you in two months kiss
what did it mean to have her by your
side in this house
yes i i don't regret having her there
because
her in that house was every single
decision i made um
we were talking about how opposites
attract on the last night because we
were talking about how we thought we
would be good in a relationship and i
said what was the biggest or what is
your biggest uh like downfall you know
yeah and she said she's an overthinker
and i said that's perfect because i
don't think at all so this is a perfect
example of why opposites attract and she
really was behind every single decision
on top of the fact that she was my
comfort in the house so having her
around was extremely important to my
game
yeah that's so nice and let's talk about
derrick x for a second because he
backdoored you essentially that's what
happened right
are you disappointed in him i know it's
a game but were you disappointed i mean
there's one thing you're saying to you
and how we handle the whole situation
with you
um
i'm disappointed because he was
successful to do it
i'm not disappointed that he put me up
because it was a very smart game move
and honestly
thinking about it now he did do what was
best for him well no he did
do what i fully believe he thought was
best for him i do fully believe that if
i were still in the house it still would
be better for his game than me being
outside the house because he is now the
biggest target i would have been a
shield and nine times out of ten if i
were sitting next to him on the block i
would have gone home still so he is now
the biggest house target and
he could have had a few more weeks if he
accepted my deal and i was still in the
house so
why do you think he didn't why why do
you think he didn't take the uh
the deal with you he um
it made the most sense it really did uh
not only did i show my trust for him
last week but the fact that he went
against that i think it's hard to for
him to believe that i would forgive him
for that but
this show really i mean my nickname kind
of on the show was golden doodle um and
in every sense of the word i am loyal
and forgiving just like a golden doodle
so i would have forgiven him i told him
that but it's hard to convince people
that
how did your mental game work like how
did this feel i mean you're a big fan of
the show you're inside the game was it
everything you expected or more
yeah it was it was exactly what i
thought honestly except i i
misprioritized things so i knew my
social game needed to be
on point
once i had a little bit of distraction
in the house
i didn't even consider the fact that it
was yeah hurting my social game which in
hindsight yes it was potentially the
reason why i went home but i don't
regret it because
there's a lot of good things that came
out of it yeah and tiffany so look like
she was advocating for you and trying to
get your voice and then she votes
against you i mean
how do you explain tiffany
tiffany in my relationship is i mean her
her son's name is christian so we have
that immediate bond by you know she
associates me with her son and that's
going to be an immediate connection to
any mother so it was genuine besides the
fact that that did work to my advantage
i we tell each other we love each other
every single night and i still do love
her but it was i definitely felt
betrayed um
not only because she didn't i didn't
have a vote but because the second i was
up on the block it didn't seem like i
had a vote and she was a person i was in
an alliance with so
i knew the alliance either meant nothing
to her or she had a better option which
now in hindsight i
aware of the better options so
i can't be mad at her and i still love
her
oh you're so sweet okay so you said you
want to be part of this game because
you're a fan it wasn't about the money
uh what was your favorite moment in the
house
favorite moment how was house was
probably
my first compliment it was the most
important compliment as well because i
am fully convinced i would have been the
first person walking out of the house if
i didn't win it so it was my first of
many comp wins i really did come to play
and meet friends i did not come for the
money which i
i think is hard to believe for a lot of
people but
yes that first win was a must win and it
felt really rewarding to have that of
course i ended up resulting alissa on
the block but
um yeah my first win was extremely
important to me and i'll remember that
forever that is special you know the
season seems unique compared to other
seasons what does it make what how would
you explain the season
um i mean that the season is definitely
diverse that was very scene based on the
first day the cast is
and and i think this cast is extremely
friendly and more um inviting than past
seasons each and every single person
that has been in this cast i want to be
friends with and have a genuine
connection outside the house and i don't
know if past seasons can say that so i'm
extremely happy to be part of it seems
like a season that's making history
i love that who do you want to win
alyssa i really hope you will
who do you think will win xavier
now i know about that
you don't think he's a threat
no he is
not only do i know about the cookout now
but he most likely has
an alliance with in the cookout he's an
extremely smart guy i know he's not just
a bartender or possibly not a bartender
at all
i really in hindsight the man goes to
bed at 10 o'clock no bartender goes to
bed at 10 o'clock
he
really is a lawyer and
i know that now he had all the greatest
points for me when i was making my pitch
and so i should have seen it coming but
i think he's going to take alyssa with
him as far as he can
but once it's time for her to go he's
going to take her out and within the
alliance he's going to go the farthest
and i think xavier is gonna gonna walk
away with a big check
they're pretty close to alyssa and
xavier right yes and i'm so happy they
are because i told her i mean she
already knew it but he is the person
that she needs to go for for everything
now um not that she can't do it on her
own because i fully believe that she can
but she just lost her number one so she
knows you need an alliance yeah she
needs someone yeah yeah and lastly who
do you think will be the next person to
leave before and who do you want to
leave i want derek x to win or i want
derek x to leave um
i do respect the fact that he did get me
out first especially when i wanted to do
it to him and had the opportunity last
week
i do want him to walk out the house
pretty much so i could say i told you so
um if you took my deal you would have
still been in the house but i told you
so and this is the reason why you're
walking out and he can't compete this
week for hoh so it's almost like taste
of his own medicine
um
i want him to walk out
i think britney will walk out though
she's interesting too easy of a target
to take out she
i guess to play devil's advocate
she has survived the block three times
but uh
i don't know if four times is gonna work
so i think she's gonna go up again it's
gonna be another
a fourth very long week for her which of
course makes me very sad because
it is not a good feeling but i think
she's going to be the next one out
congratulations to you coming this far
and winning those comps and we're so
happy to watch you on the show so
congratulations and i just got a golden
doodle so
yes you are a golden duo so thank you so
much
thank you nice speaking with you
you